Speaker 1: This is super interesting and very
much worth spending some time on today.
There is a guy named Alex Berenson.
Alex Berenson is not a doctor, but has been
front and center throughout the pandemic,
making tons of claims about the virus, about
the pandemic itself, about containment guidelines,
about masks, vaccination, the spread of the
virus he has.
Been wrong on essentially everything, there
is a very good article you can read about
him in the Atlantic called The Pandemics Wrongest
Man, just some of his greatest hits include
blaming vaccines for more coronavirus cases,
suppressing the immune system, saying Israel
suffered from being early to vaccinate, that
the vaccine side effects are worse than covid
itself for anybody other than seniors.
I could go on and on.
I mean, he's just been wrong about everything.
I can't think of anybody who's been this wrong.
Maybe Trump.
Right.
But but it just weaponized wrongness is what
I would call it.
He is also a big anti cannabis guy, very much
against marijuana.
He's even written books about how bad marijuana
is.
The books are trash.
They're filled with anecdotes and cherry picked
so-called data.
So yesterday, Alex Berenson goes on.
Tucker Carlson, I guess Tucker has a new daytime
show.
It's a second show called Tucker Tucker Carlson.
Today, you can distinguish the shows because
on his nighttime show, Tucker's wearing a
tie on his daytime show.
Tucker is not wearing a tie.
I watched a two minute clip.
Tucker and Alex Berenson talking about cannabis.
I was actually stunned at how much incorrect
information is squeezed into such a short
period of time.
There must be some record here for falsehoods
per minute.
Let's just jump right into it and start seeing
if we can understand what's going on.
Speaker 3: Community will acknowledge that
cannabis can cause, you know, a fair number
of people, especially if you use heavily to
have kind of short term psychotic reactions.
Right.
A bad trip.
But they're peaceful, though, because marijuana
makes you peaceful.
Yeah, it's the Mahatma Gandhi.
That's right.
That's why that's why violence has gone down
so much in the United States in five years.
Speaker 1: OK, so you heard Berentson there
sarcastically say, you know, if marijuana
made people mellow and docile, violent crime
has gone down in the last five years, implying
violent crime is actually up over the last
five years.
Now, there is a reason, he says, in the last
five years, because crime in the United States,
big picture has been on the decline for a
really long time.
If you look at FBI data for violent crimes
per 100000 people, violent victimizations
per thousand people age 12 or over, property
crimes per 100000 people, property victimizations
per thousand households, they have all been
down, down, down over the last twenty eight
years or longer.
Now, it is true that with some indicators,
the decline sort of slowed down, maybe even
went up and then back down.
Over the last five to seven years, it's been
a less steady trend.
Alex Berenson apparently wants you to think
that because of marijuana law, crime is now
going up because marijuana does not actually
make people docile.
It makes people violent.
Every aspect of this claim is wrong.
First, there's no evidence that marijuana
makes people violent.
Second, we started seeing decriminalization
of cannabis in 1973, medical cannabis legalization
in nineteen ninety six, recreational cannabis
legalization in 2012.
That's already nine years ago.
So even the timeline he implies a causality
for which there is no evidence.
And he also points to a timeline that doesn't
actually correlate with cannabis law.
Violent crime has been declining.
The up and down period doesn't correlate with
cannabis law changes.
It's just vapid.
Let's watch a little bit more of this.
So you think that there is I mean, I'm just
Speaker 3: being completely honest.
I grew up in Southern California.
I smoked marijuana as a child.
Everyone I knew believed that it mellowed
you out.
Right.
So we're saying there's evidence of the opposite.
Oh, yeah.
There's I mean, again, so this is there's
something called cannabis cannabinoid, hyperemesis
syndrome, OK?
What that basically means is uncontrolled
vomiting as a result of THC.
Yes.
I've seen how cannabis is supposed to settle.
You settle your stomach, you know, if you're
nauseated, smoke some sort of one of the famous
uses of it, of course, for chemotherapy, chemo
patients.
That's right.
But it looks like there's this paradoxical
effect if you use too much of it, that for
whatever reason somehow resets the receptors
in the brain for some people.
And they have this just terrible uncontrolled
vomiting and in some cases can actually kill.
There's I'm not exaggerating because you become
so dehydrated.
It can kill you if you're not careful, if
you don't get to an emergency room.
Speaker 1: OK, now, did you see what he did
there?
First, he says there's this thing called cannabinoid
hyperemesis syndrome, where super high intake
of THC in some people could cause uncontrolled.
Vomiting Now, that part is true, that exists,
and with countless substances, medications,
you can have one effect at a normal dose and
the opposite effect at a cartoonishly high
dose.
There's no question of that.
That's not specific to THC.
It's insanely rare with THC, but it is not
exclusive to THC.
Then he says, well, it can kill you if you
become super dehydrated from the vomiting
and you don't go to a hospital and deal with
the dehydration.
We're no longer talking about cannabis.
So I understand the game that he's playing
here.
Anything that causes you to become dehydrated,
if you don't deal with the dehydration, you
could die.
And if you are uncontrollably vomiting for
a long time, then you should be going to the
hospital, regardless of whether it's as a
result of extremely cartoonishly high THC
intake.
So he mixes something that could happen to
someone who consumes an insane amount of THC.
But then he's admitting the risk isn't actually
from the cannabis.
It's anything that causes uncontrollable vomiting
and subsequent dehydration.
It could be a stomach bug, could be food poisoning,
could be for a whole bunch of other reasons.
He's sort of slick, but it doesn't take very
long to see through the nonsense.
Let's just watch a little bit more
Speaker 3: so so paradoxically, you know,
so in the short term, marijuana can reduce
anxiety, certainly, and it can get you high.
But like most antianxiety drugs, you can have
bad rebound anxiety if you try to quit.
I mean, that's true of benzodiazepines.
That's a known risk of further cannabis has
this effect on people where it makes them
paranoid.
Some people some of the time.
OK, and if you have this predisposition or
if you're sliding into mental illness and
you start smoking a lot, you may sort of temporarily
muffle that anxiety at the cost of your paranoid
symptoms getting worse.
Speaker 1: OK, so again, now he's talking
about some people get side effects that are
rare and may be counterproductive to what
you're trying to treat.
You might take cannabis for anxiety and it
makes you paranoid, which then makes you more
anxious.
Yeah, that's true.
This is the case with SSRI for depression
and anxiety, which in some people, short term,
medium term, you take an SSRI for anxiety.
It might cause anxiety.
You take it for depression.
It could make your depression worse.
This is not new.
It's not unique to cannabis.
So it's if you actually go through it, it's
a worthless segment.
There is nothing of substantive value here.
And increasingly, the right is holding up
Alex Berenson as some kind of brilliant truth
teller who we should listen to because everybody
else is lying to us.
But Alex Berenson is telling us the truth,
increasingly a dangerous guy and increasingly
being held up as a hero by right wing media.
We'll have more about this on the show's Instagram
page.
Make sure you're following us there at The
David Pakman Show.
And you can follow me on Instagram at David
Pakman